a push for change by just opening a book
Henderson Librarians are hoping to make
a difference and Elevate young minds
with reading Lauren O'Grady is live this
morning to talk about the 500 books
before Middle School challenge Lauren
good morning to you
good morning yes it's for kiddos 6 to 11
years old now 500 books may sound like a
lot but Library staff here to break it
down two books a week 104 a year joined
by Carrie Jensen here senior Youth
Services specialist now Carrie what is
the overarching goal with this our goal
is really just to make kids become
lifelong readers to help them out on
their journey and to be a part of it
perfect and what are some trends that
we're seeing here nationally to Spur
this
honestly reading scores are just going
down across the nation so we are just
trying to
help reverse that a little bit and play
our part in getting them back on point
and now we spoke to a kid earlier the
Holmes family they're here weekly Finn
is a second grader who already hit the
210 books he may finish it this year
what are some other testimonies you're
hearing from families about what this
really does for their kids these
families are just excited to have a
reason for their kiddos to be reading
outside of school and to be able to come
in and have encouragement and motivation
and get some kind of outside reward in
order to make reading more fun great
thank you so much you can sign up on the
Henderson library's website and their
beanstack app love of reading it's a
great program here back to you guys all
right Lauren thank you very much good
stuff there in Henderson love it